Now here, just because the fact 3 approximation algorithm
for vertex cover doesn't carry over here
doesn't mean doesn't mean there can not be an approximation algorithm
for Clique and Independent Set;
it's just that we can not use this one.
So Bob and Carol still don't have to be unhappy,
but unfortunately, I'm now going to make them very unhappy.
For Clique and Independent set,
there is no constant factor approximation algorithm
unless P equals NP.
That, of course, is a very unpleasant surprise
and it's very surprising,
so where did I get that from?
Well, the proof for this result here
relies on some very, very deep results
of theoretical computer science
which you will only get to know in very advanced
theoretical computer science courses, if ever.
But what I would like to do is just give you an intuitive idea
for why there is no constant factor approximation algorithm
for Clique and Independent Set
unless P equals NP.